[Applause]
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat up here.
Heat
up here.
[Music]
[Applause]
Heat
[Music]
up here.
Heat up here.
[Music]
[Applause]
I charge the power fans. This video
comes to you from a corn field located
in southwest Indiana where a 16 row 30in
John Deere C16F folding corn head is
harvesting the crop paired with a 690
engine horsepower 460 bushel John Deere
X9100 combine. In this video, I would
like to share with you the abilities of
this 40 foot wide corn head as well as
its production history,
specifications, and list price tag. But
first, let's head out to the field so
you can see and hear all this harvesting
action.
[Applause]
[Music]
Heat up here.
Heat
up here.
[Music]
[Applause]
The 40 foot wide, 16 row, 30in space
John Deere C6. 16F folding corn head was
introduced in model year 2020 as part of
the company's range of C series corn
heads which includes nine different
models of rigid and folding headers
manufactured at John Deere's Harvester
Works located in East Molen, Illinois.
The corn heads range from the C6R six
row 30in head all the way up to the
C18F 20in folding corn head. The C16F is
equipped with a 19in augur which allows
the header to consume a large amount of
corn. The C16F can harvest 65 more acres
per day than a 12 row 30in space corn
head. Paired with an
X9100, this header allows the large
combine to harvest 7,200 bushels of corn
per hour. The farm featured in this
video is harvesting their crop with two
John Deere X9100 combines equipped with
the
C16F corn head. The combines harvest
14,400 bushels of corn per hour. that
requires four J&M 1150 grain carts with
a carrying capacity of
1,150 bushels. The carts are operated by
four 620 engine horsepower John Deere
9620 RX tractors. It takes a fleet of 13
semi trucks to haul the corn away from
all this harvesting action. The C16F, in
addition to picking corn in a hurry,
also helps to size and reduce the amount
of residue out in the field. It's
equipped with Romax chopping stock
rolls, which help chop up the stocks
into pieces that are 6 in or less, which
help speed up the breakdown and burial
of the residue left out in the field
without it washing or blowing away. The
headers are also equipped with John
Deere stock deflectors which are used to
push down the stubble and fracture it
which again helps in the breakdown of
the residue and it also reduces the
chance of damage to the tires and tracks
on the combines. These deflectors are
placed behind each row unit across the
header. You can see from the aerial
views of the video how the Romax units
and stock stompers leave the residue in
the field as flat as a pancake. The
outside points on the
C16F cornhead snouts light up at night.
This feature allows the farmer to have
better visibility of the 40ft wide
cornet from inside the cab as well as
the grain cart operator to have a good
view of where the corn head ends and how
far they need to be away from the
combine. This header's ability to fold
up speeds up the harvesting process.
When it goes into transport mode, it
drops down from 40 feet wide to
20.75 ft. Being able to leave the header
attached to the combine and move on to
the next field saves a lot of time
without the hassle of loading it onto a
header wagon and moving it separately
from the combine. The C16F weighs in at
[Music]
13,462 lb. And according to John
Deere.com, it has a list price of
$270,520 for model year 2022. The C16F
corn head featured in this video is
attached to a John Deere X9100 combine.
This machine was introduced in model
year 2020 and went into full production
for model year 2021. It's manufactured
at the company's Harvester Works located
in East Molen, Illinois. It's powered by
a 13.6 L John Deere Power Tech 830 cubic
in engine rated at 690 engine
horsepower. It threshes grain using a
pair of 24 in diameter, 11 1/2 ft long
rotors. It has a grain bin storage
capacity of 460 bushels that unloads
through a 31 ft augur at 5.3 bushels per
second. According to John Deere.com, the
list price for an X9100 combine for mall
year 2022 is 921,348.
[Applause]
[Music]
Heat
up here.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
I think that's good.
[Music]
I'm up in the cab of the John Deere X9
1100 combine and we're harvesting corn
today with
a John Deere C 16F stock master.
This is probably
about heat.
Heat
up here.
Heat up here.
I hope you've enjoyed spending some time
out in the field hearing and seeing the
capabilities of the 16 row 30in John
Deere
C16F cornhead paired with the X9 1100
combine. I'd like to hear in the comment
section below this video if you raise
corn on your farm. Tell me about the
combine that you're operating and the
corn head that you use with it. If
you've enjoyed this video, consider
subscribing to Big Tractor Power YouTube
where there's over 2,000 videos of farm
machines in action. If you would like to
see additional harvesting content from
the channel, continue to watch for a few
more seconds to the end screen for a
direct link to more Big Tractor Power
YouTube videos. As always, thank you for
watching.
[Music]